hear me say you're worth it you're worth  it you're worth it god almighty you're  worth it  get with somebody you trust give it a  counselor give us someone and say i  gotta start anew  today because he's mental health crisis  a 1.9 trillion dollar coronavirus  release package passed last march  includes billions of dollars to prevent  and treat mental health and substance  abuse disorders  so many of this stuff starts in our  house  quit telling your kids that your  teachers want to kill them stop quit  telling them that doctors all want them  dead  stop go tell them the government's  trying to kill them quit you're going to  make your kids bananas  start saying things like people are  doing the best they can with the info  they got  i disagree with some of that information  but i know people are working hard